hi I'm Eric Voss an Avengers end game
released one of its opening scenes
confirming major theories and bringing
up even more questions changing the way
we look at this movie from mildly
obsessive to full-blown conspiracy I'm
gonna break down this scene and explain
all the interesting clues that you might
have missed it spoiler warning in case I
get anything right in ruin so the
in-game cast went on Good Morning
America to promote the film and they
shared this early scene in which the
Avengers debate over whether to rush
into a quick-fix plan to go after Thanos
to steal the gauntlet using their new
weights and a whole Captain Marvel let's
watch the first part of the scene use
the stones again we'd be going in
short-handed you know look he's still
got the stones so that's gonna use them
to bring everyone back just like that
yeah just like that so to me the most
intriguing part of this scene is the
first line for Black Widow she says he
used the stones again this brings up two
questions first what did thinness use
the stones this latest time to do
perhaps is just something simple to
teleport with the space stone something
we know creates an energy signal or
maybe to heal himself since Thor's
Stormbreaker must have left a pretty
nasty gash in his chest
maybe the Avengers got Thanos his
medical bill in the mail by mistake and
now they're like he's walking again
let's break his legs and steal his rocks
but keep in mind that the Avengers are
talking about bringing everyone back
with thanasis gauntlet based on however
he just used it so maybe that's what
Thanos did he could have brought back
some of his fallen allies the Black
Order the outriders maybe even the
Chitauri but not the other he sucks
but then what about Gamora or why about
Gamora
could dannis have used the stones to
commune with her once again in the soul
stone perhaps he's feeling the heavy
emotional burden of taking half of all
life from the universe and finding that
the best form of therapy is talking to a
little ghost girl inside one of his gems
but look again at that shot of Black
Widow she's examining a hollow
projection of a planet and that appears
to be what they're reacting to that
surface has the colorful golden glow
that Thanos's new farm planet had at the
end of infinity war and that planet is
called Titan to Thanos reportedly
established it as a kind of reset on
his original home planet Titan which
died out due to ecological factors of
the population overconsumption of
resources people parking too much
whatever was so maybe the act that
Thanos used the stones for was terra
formation kind of like ego did in
guardians volume to creating new life a
new planet new corn if we Rick Sanchez
ever lands here he's gonna freak the
out this brings us to the second
question how could the Avengers know
that Thanos used the Infinity stones
again well if Thanos did create a new
planet Titan - showing up on the star
map could just be what alerts them
confirming that he used the stones again
and confirming where he is and that his
gauntlet is still operational rocket or
Captain Marvel could have some advanced
tech that allows them to track the
gauntlets location and energy signal
from across the galaxy it's also
possible that Captain Marvel could have
witnessed Thanos with the gauntlet
before she got to earth but there's also
the theory that they could have rigged
one of the stones so that they can track
its coordinates like Shuri could have
done that with a mine stone before she
had to bail on her operation to try to
remove it from visions head but let's
move on to the next clip from this thing
how do we know it's gonna end any
differently than it did before because
before you didn't have me everybody in
this room is about that superhero life
and if you don't mind my asking where
the hell have you been all this time
there are a lot of other planets in the
universe and unfortunately they didn't
have you guys so ah
so this answers the question that we've
been asking about Captain Marvel why
hasn't she come to help the Avengers and
past apocalyptic conflicts
well apparently because she was saving
every other planet in the galaxy from
their past apocalyptic complex he a jerk
or this is just a very convenient excuse
for Carol to cover the truth that she
was really kicking back on a squirrel
resort and left her pager in the room
now even though we saw the next footage
and past trailers I want you to pay very
close attention to this next clip
[Music]
okay this is gonna sound nuts but a lot
of folks are saying and now I cannot
unhear it that you can hear a voice
whisper I have telepathy
[Music]
so is Carol Danvers suddenly telepathic
to be clear telepathy is not
historically one of captain Marvel's
powers she sometimes has something
called a seventh sense but that allows
her to sense upcoming terrible events
knots that speak to a scardy ins even if
she was telepathic why would I have
telepathy be what she says
telepathically it'd be like a scroll
shape-shifting into a guy wearing a
shirt that says shapeshifter maybe
Captain Marvel somehow gained the power
of telepathy and now she's trying to
signal before another reason that she's
a badass that he should go into battle
with and I guess Thor just doesn't react
or maybe we're hearing the voice of
someone off-screen
like Jean Grey a very literal Jean Grey
hiding behind a bookcase or something
look I'm kind of creeped out I don't
know what the hell's going on I'm
thinking this could be a case of a
phenomenon called audio pareidolia
that's where when you hear random noises
if someone beforehand tells you to
listen for a specific word or freeze
your brain will actually perceive
hearing that exact phrase even when
there's nothing there kind of like when
you were more likely to hear it as
Laurel if someone told you it was Laurel
because evolution that's up when we see
patterns where none exists and maybe all
this really is is a random alignment of
the music of characters sighing Thor
chewing on his Hawaiian sweet rolls and
shoes moving across the floor and it all
just kind of links together and it
sounds because one condition do hear it
this way as the words I have telepathy
or Jane Grey hide am I in a bookcase
let's move on to the last clip
[Music]
let's go get this language so this seems
to confirm a theory I brought up before
that the Avengers will rush into a
half-baked assault on Thanos early in
the movie now we know this is early
because black widows hair clock tells us
that it's still half past blonde not yet
a quarter tail long and red it's fair
for them to assume Captain Marvel will
be enough to take on Thanos her power
was derived from the space stone
suggesting that like Scarlet Witch her
stone derived powers are enough to
destroy a stone or at least be better
than the others at holding Thanos back
and let's remember Thor's Stormbreaker
was itself nearly strong enough to bring
down Thanos if he just aimed a little
higher the problem is this mission is
all but certain to fail if it's this
early in the movie there's just no way a
direct assault on Thanos will make
things better if they beat Thanos in the
first act it would all be like 30 maybe
40 minutes not the three hours of
goodies that we've been promised
actually I think this early charge is
more likely to make things a lot worse
for the Avengers like a second snap or
maybe just a snap of one character's
neck like Captain Marvel even with hair
clocks it's not easy to assemble the
exact scene-by-scene timeline of the end
game's first act which I prefer honestly
because believe it or not I don't want
to predict these movies scene by scene
it's just fun to speculate permissible
Clues the various insane directions they
could go but I am assuming that this
conversation precedes the return of Tony
and nebula as well as the return of
Scott Lang and I don't think Hawkeye
will join up with them until later here
clock is striking long and red there but
based on a shot of several of these
eager Avengers in the recent
special.look trailer in the cockpit of
the benatar i think that stark and
banner will refuse to join on this
doomed mission perhaps seeing its
futility and instead decided to work
with Scott Lang on whatever quantum
technology he's going on about and that
will ultimately be how they come up with
a way to undo snap for good but assuming
this early mission fails which character
do you think will pay for it with their
life comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on instagram and
twitter at EI vas and subscribe to the
new rock stars for deep dives into
everything in-game related and a
reminder if you plan to go to VidCon
this
here we would love to join you so please
tweet at vidcon to let them know that
you'd love to see us host a panel or a
live show Ramin and greed we just want
to meet you guys hang out be best
friends thank you for watching in hey
even if the Avengers fail I still hope
that well it's a quote cap they get that
mother docking
[Music]